all right there are other people running
for the 2024 Republican nomination one
of those people is Nikki Haley Nikki
Haley had an event she spoke at an event
and it was embarrassing it was low
energy rivaling Jeb Bush in 2016. it
makes Jeb Bush look electric from 2016.
and the event seems totally brain dead
and Nikki Haley's campaign continues to
remain Dead on Arrival this was the SBA
list HQ event in Virginia
and I think that means Small Business
Association list headquarters
she
for some reason to the SBA spoke about
abortion
I don't know what's worse the level of
energy or the arguments that Nikki Haley
is making the next president must find
National consensus
that might sound strange to many people
under row consensus was replaced by
demonization and let's be honest most in
the media prioritize demonization
they stoked division putting pitting
Americans against each other
no one talks about finding consensus
everyone goes to the barricades and
attacks the other side
they've turned a sensitive issue that
has long divided people into a kind of
isn't this inspiring to bidding more
how many weeks are you for how many
exceptions are you for and the list goes
on
but these questions miss the point if
the goal is about saving as many lives
as possible
you don't save any lives if you can't
enact your position into law and you
can't do that unless you find consensus
reaching consensus starts with
humanizing not demonizing
just like I have my story
I respect everyone who has their story
I don't judge someone who is pro-choice
any more than I want them to judge me
for being pro-life so she says some
things that are fine like let's not
judge each other and try to find
consensus and have compassion and
whatever else but this is just not
moving the needle and I'll tell you
where the polling is in a moment but
just just a completely whatever the
opposite of an electrifying campaign
would be that's what Nikki Haley seems
to be running she also commented about
how she feels when people decide not to
go through with a pregnancy Michael and
I struggle to have children of Our Own
I had many challenges as a teenager into
my college Years I went through numerous
surgeries
when Michael and I were married I
couldn't wait to be a mom
but what happened so easily for many of
my friends
was not my path we went through
countless sessions of fertility
treatments
every day I wake up and see or speak to
my two children I feel blessed the
greatest job I will ever have is being
their mom
our eldest daughter got married just 10
days ago
I will never forget the day she was born
and then seeing her walk down the
wedding I don't know what it is about
these speeches that Nikki Haley gives
like the These are nice touching stories
in some abstract sense so your daughter
being born your daughter's wedding day
compassion empathy but I I don't know if
it's like how the stories are written
for her and she reads that there's
something about this that couldn't
possibly be less interesting oh with her
dad
I felt what countless parents feel love
Pride overwhelming Joy
I believe every life is a blessing from
God yeah my heart hurts when someone
decides not to go through with a
pregnancy okay so in terms of how this
is going it's hard to imagine Nikki
Haley even making it to the first
primary but I guess she's going to stick
around long enough to debate if we look
at recent polling here we have an ipsos
Reuters poll where Haley is pulling
three percent we have a morning consult
poll where Haley is polling three
percent we have a big Village poll where
Haley is pulling six percent that's a B
minus rated poll so you know she's sort
of like three percent Nikki I guess is
where we are at this point in time so
listen I don't take away anything from
anybody's right and ability to run and
her desire I'm sure I guess is genuine
and unless she's auditioning for VP in
which it's sort of like a publicity tour
but I do wonder and I know I've said
this before and whenever I mention it
people in my audience seem to not be on
the same page I've asked before when
someone like Nikki Haley talks
presumably to advisors and her family
and decides to run
does she actually think to herself okay
let's see I'm pulling three percent
Trump already has 53 percent
here's my path to winning like does she
actually think she could win
or is it more of a
I think I could get some positive
attention if I do this even though I
know I'm not going to win whenever I
bring this up some people write to me
and say no David people become like
almost like delusional and they think
they could possibly win and other people
write to me and go now David of course
you understand she can't win and Chris
Christie knows he can't win and Vivek
ramaswamy knows he can't win but they
calculate that it's worth running for
some other reason I don't know the
answer but it's very difficult to
imagine how Nikki Haley could look at
the situation and think I can win and I
can win by making quite literally the
least interesting speeches in the world
about abortion to the Small Business
Association it's crazy to me let me know
what you think we're going to take a
quick break we will hear from Rhonda
McDaniel after the break we'll talk
about the Trump rape trial that has
started many many other things to
discuss stay with us we'll be back right
after this